this freshly refurbished prison ring in
the town of Vonda no VA will host
Frances potential terrorists at least
until authorities have assessed how
dangerous they are
we'll have to question the inmates with
a team of educators probation officers
and psychologists will then you to put
them in solitary confinement if they're
extremely dangerous and radicalized or
they'll be sent to a wing that has its
own special team that's for those who
don't seem on the brink of committing an
attack but could incite others to do so
the inmates will then be sent to
dedicated prison sections these will be
completely sealed off from other prison
blocks and have their own dedicated
guards disappear may no home for you
contact I think that it's really
important to completely isolate
radicalized inmates and make sure that
they don't spread their radical Salafist
ideas especially to vulnerable people or
to those who are a bit lost the prison
sections are part of the government's
new de-radicalization strategy it
involves a 60 point plan to help detect
radicalized people in companies the
administration or sports clubs Omaha a
clip is supposed to show how to resist
radical preaching but critics say the
strategy is hardly getting down to the
root of the problem the possibility it's
the government's responsibility to
defend the country protect its people
and oversee their education but the new
strategy is almost exclusively about
defense and protecting people there's
almost nothing on education and yet that
would be the most effective weapon in
the fight against radicalization study
says French politicians too often
stigmatized Muslims in a bid to win
votes we Muslims often have to justify
ourselves and disassociate ourselves
from barbaric acts and
of our making but we are part of this
nation and Muslims are the main victims
of terror attacks plus by blaming us
the politicians are playing into the
hands of radical Islamists they can then
tell marginalized young people that
France doesn't like its Muslims anyway
the prison administration just like the
government points to the French
principle of lai city or the separation
of church and state nominal it
controller an occasionally called
Belgium in the fight against
radicalization
there's the Belgian approach they
cooperate closely with religious
representatives to try and teach their
inmates a peaceful Islam we have a
different approach we don't want to
change people's religious ideas we just
want to prevent them from proceeding to
action the government says the strategy
is working and that last year alone 20
terror attacks were prevented across
France at least one of them was planned
from inside a prison